this video is sponsored by athletic
greens and to be honest with you this is
one that I'm really excited to talk
about athletic greens was kind enough to
send me a 30-day supply of ag-1 which is
an all-in-one nutritional drink that
does a lot of really awesome things for
your body like supporting your immunity
and improving your mood Focus gut health
energy and just a whole bunch more and
let me be honest with you this was
perfect for me because I'll admit I have
never had that healthy of a diet so
historically I've always struggled with
energy levels and such but speaking from
my heart after taking a minute to drink
ag1 in the mornings for more than 20
days now I sleep better I think better I
have more energy to work and go to the
gym every day and I just feel better and
it complies with any lifestyle choices
like keto or paleo or veganism so I've
even got a lot of my friends and family
members trying it out too whether you're
a homebody or an athlete I cannot
recommend drinking ag1 enough they have
a brand new long time subscriber in me
and if you're curious about improving
your health in pretty much every way
click my link in the description below
to get a one year supply of immune
boosting vitamin D3 K2 and 5 travel
packs for free with your first purchase
we've only got one life each so let's
take care of it yeah and now on to the
video a Zelda game without bosses is
like biscuits without gravy Jam or
butter my fellow Southerners will get
that one like yeah you might have a
super yummy biscuit that's all warm and
fluffy but without any toppings where's
the hearty flavor the Tangy fruitius the
melty butter The Legend of Zelda tears
of the Kingdom fixed something that a
lot of fans had a problem with in its
predecessor and that is the addition of
new unique bosses that serve to flavor
up the biscuit that is the world of
Hyrule now before we dive head first
into the Waters of explanation we've got
to cover a disclaimer to check for rocks
because if okay I'm done with these
weird metaphors for now basically a
couple disclaimers to get through some
of the bosses and tears of the kingdom
are in fact carry over bosses from
breath of the wild such as the stone
palaces hynixes or lionels and as such
will not be retouched in this video
since their explanations carry over
pretty seamlessly if you swap anytime I
mention malice for gloom second there
are still quite a few brand new bosses
and tears of the Kingdom over 13 to be
exact and because of this larger number
instead of placing them all in one large
video I'm going to split this video up
into two parts with most bosses being
present in this video and one or more
bigger bosses in the second and you know
YouTube has been known to be a bit Moody
with its notifications even for
subscribers if it thinks something isn't
trendy so whether or not Zelda is a
trending subject right now make sure
you're subscribed and have that Bell on
so that you know when part two gets
uploaded remember you can always turn it
off later if you change your mind anyway
that's all I've got for disclaimer so
without further Ado here we go Endo yeah
spoiler alert obviously right off the
bat we're going to tackle explaining the
bosses that all have something in common
and that would be the majority of the
bosses in the game that appear to be
either creations of pure Gloom or Gloom
infused Wildlife or remains of organic
material such as the gibdos not unlike
the bosses that were created out of
malice from Brother of the wild the
bosses that fit this criteria would
include the gliox colguera moragia
marveled Goma the muktarak the boss
bakoblin the queen gibdo and the Phantom
ganons obviously the one thing the vast
majority of monsters from both breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom have
in common is ganon's malice or
ganondorf's Gloom respectively but that
doesn't mean that there aren't still
details to be uncovered about each of
these monsters boss mccobbins for
instance were not present in breath of
the wild yet are present in tears of the
Kingdom implying heavily that the events
of the upheaval are what led directly to
their existence which is to say that
Link and Zelda waking Ganondorf up at
the beginning of the game and releasing
the full power of His Gloom into the
world is what directly led to the
existence of not only the bakoblins but
the boss the Goblins which are literally
just bigger variants Of the Goblins That
Swing bigger weapons as the result of
being you know bigger and bigger is
better since they are bigger better
they're normally the leaders of their
little bekabling gangs and lead the
whole troop around in their little
patrols which is kind of cute and willed
the most power of the Boko weapons and
you know how in the last game everyone
was scared whenever they encountered a
Lionel well in this game that feeling is
still there but for the new powerful
three-headed dragons called King
ghidorahs I mean gliox which come in
four varieties flame Frost Thunder and
King which is a combination of all three
tons of fun these dragons are directly
said to have only appeared after the
upheaval which again proves that they
are creations of Gloom that were
released upon the world following
ganondorf's Reawakening interestingly
enough this is not the only time the
gliac boss dragon has been seen in the
series actually a glioc is an original
enemy with its first appearance being in
the first game The Legend of Zelda where
it appears three times as two three and
four-headed versions of itself they've
appeared in some of the handheld Zelda
Titles since then but they're terrifying
tears of the Kingdom appearance is the
first time we've seen the formidable
beasties on a Home console since the
beginning of the series and who knows
why Ganondorf decided to make them maybe
the original gliox were also creations
of that Ganon meaning this is just a
good old Ganondorf original Monster
design or maybe he was just a big fan of
the original game who knows colgar is an
interesting boss to encounter in the
game because not only is it a huge
flying ice monster that's powerful
enough to plunge an entire region into a
permanent blizzard but it's also
remarkably similar to an earlier boss in
the franchise the mulgera in both its
name and its design both monsters are
large flying Serpentine creatures that
freely manipulate and travel through not
only the air but the elements they are
bound to with kulgera's element being
ice and mulger as being sand the other
part that's interesting about colguera
is its first appearance being inside the
ominous wind temple high above the Rito
Village but that's another explanation
for the upcoming lore of the dungeons
video have I mentioned that you should
be subscribed anyway colgaris similarity
to mulgera extends to the fact that even
moguera was a creation of ganondorf's
back in the Wind Waker so once again
perhaps this monster design is either a
Ganondorf original or a literal
resurrection of the monster mulguera
although that's purely speculative
colgarian most of the other dungeon
bosses in the game can all be
encountered in multiple different places
in the depths after being defeated in
their corresponding dungeons which means
there are multiples of each again
proving their existence as pure
creations of Gloom moving on the next
Gloom boss would be the queen gibdo
which is a terrifying combination of
giant flying insect and the literal
Undead now to my knowledge there has
never been a monster quite like this in
the series before we have faced giant
insects before and we've even faced
giant Undead before but never a giant
flying insect Undead that seems like
ground that shouldn't have been crossed
but hey here we are the queen gibdo
appears to Simply Be a giant super
mutated moth gibdo which similarly to
the queen also fly with moth wings and
can aggressively spit at link to hurt
him all of the gibdo and tears of the
Kingdom the queen included share the
weakness to light that the re-deads from
earlier games in the series also do
which heavily implies a connection
between the two types of enemies that
connection being the dark Unholy
reanimation of human corpses the queen
can also produce large amounts of sand
enough to cover the entire Gerudo desert
region in a sand shroud whilst releasing
the reanimated moth and regular gibdos
into the area to hunt the living creepy
stuff the Tiny But Mighty muck to rock
which was responsible for covering the
entire Zora region in a goopy substance
called sludge appears to really just be
a glue mutated octarok which is quite
blatantly proven by the fact that it
drops octo balloons OCTA Rock eyeballs
and even octarok Tentacles when defeated
in the depths so that was pretty mucking
simple moving on though the next boss is
the marbled Rock roast I know the
substance is technically just called
gloom Rock but I want to call it marbled
Rock roast and marbled Rock roast is
literally responsible for the following
three bosses unibo maragia and marbled
Goma and yes I do mean that unibo from
breath of the wild Universe was visited
by the fake Princess Zelda that was
really just a phantom Ganon in Disguise
and given a strange mask to wear that
altered his personality and made him
feed marbled Rock roasts to the citizens
of Goron City leading to all of them
becoming gloom-fluenced as well when he
was under the influence he did end up
upgrading his wardrobe a bit and
becoming a mob boss though so I can't be
too mad at him plus he snaps out of it
once link beats the mask off of him the
maragia is an interesting boss because
it is clearly named to be a reference to
volvagia which is the legendary fire
dragon that once lived within Death
Mountain and was defeated by the hero of
time wielding the mighty Megaton Hammer
maragi appears to literally be a living
rock monster though so there's not too
much to explain here without pure leaps
of speculation like if I were to say
that it's possible that moragia is
literally the reincarnated Spirit of
volvagia given rock form I mean its
design is pretty draconic and serves to
further solidify its references to the
dragon volvagia who has been long dead
at this point so I would say why
couldn't it be a possibility the final
monster that marbled Rock roast is
responsible for creating would be the
marbled Goma a huge four-legged one-eyed
spider-like monster encased in rock that
can produce unlimited amounts of Gloom
Rock and right off the bat veteran fans
of the series will recognize the name
Goma from several appearances of the
other monsters and bosses all name the
same thing that makes several
appearances across the franchise always
appearing as a one-eyed arachnid type
monster and uh perhaps it would be more
accurate to say that the marbled Goma is
the one responsible for the marbled Rock
roast according to the compendium the
marbled Goma is the one that spread
Gloom rock across the entire Elden
region meaning Gloom rock is literally
marbled goma's secretions
delicious just like the other dungeons
bosses marbled Goma has callbacks to
earlier bosses from the franchise
implying that either Ganondorf keeps his
designs or perhaps some monsters
reincarnate alongside the demon king and
the spirit of the hero now there's a
thought the final Gloom creation bossed
a tackle before moving on would be the
Gloom spawns also known as the Phantom
ganons and strangely enough I feel like
their actual Phantom Ganon appearance is
less terrifying than their Gloom spawn
appearance espec when they start
shrieking at you and the sky turns blood
red now Phantom ganons have been around
in the franchise for some time with the
first appearance of the iconic foe being
an Ocarina of Time and subsequent
appearing in the Wind Waker four Swords
Adventures and breath of the wild as the
blight ganons in tears of the Kingdom
though this Ganondorf had the bright
idea of literally duplicating himself
since he's such a good fighter and
sending these duplicates out into the
world with Weaponry to seek link out in
order to you know make him not alive
anymore interestingly the compendium
states that Phantom ganons are made of
ganondorf's own flesh and blood and
since they are creations of Gloom this
would therefore logically imply that
Gloom can be described as the Flesh and
Blood Of The Demon King and this would
make sense given that the amount of the
goopy substance known as Gloom leaking
out of his body seems to directly
correlate with his dry dehydrated
appearance but more on that in the next
video Believe It or Not There were
actually some bosses in tears of the
Kingdom that were not created by
ganondorf's Gloom well four to be exact
the first would be the brand new wild
monster species introduced in the game
the fraxes these giant frog-like
beasties appear to be some sort of
evolution of a frog that also somehow
bonded with zonite which all fruxes
including the little babies drop upon
defeat their Japanese name is degugama
which is literally a Corruption of the
word gamma which means frog they are
completely nocturnal and are shown to
hate the light actively attacking any
sort of light Bloom that link places
anywhere and as such they only live deep
down in the Dark of The Depths which
means their history is likely tied to
the history of the depths itself which
is tied to the history of the zonai
themselves but for the time being they
appear to simply be natural Wildlife
that can grow quite massive and really
likes to catch a quick meal by opening
their gaping mouths and waiting for a
little person to fall in be careful
spelunking next and speaking of the
zonai we have the flux constructs which
are well giant zonite constructs created
out of multiple giant Zone eye blocks
which move around using a zonai force
that looks similar to ultra hand which
is a zonai ability seriously though as a
little side note most things in tears of
the Kingdom that are mysterious can be
explained by just saying the zonai it's
possible they were created to assist in
workload includes by perhaps
transporting mining efforts but that
seems rather unlikely to me since each
and every flux construct is located on a
circular Battlefield or a battlefield of
some sort with some literally being on
their own little Battlefield Island it
appears to be quite obvious that these
constructs were created purely for trial
by combat and if the theory that all Sky
Islands were raised into the skies above
for the purposes of preparing link to
face Ganondorf is to be believed then
therefore these constructs were created
literally for link just like the other
training constructs and constructs of
all kinds in all the shrines but on the
other hand if you believe the sky
islands may have been up there for a
while but obscured by the magical Cloud
barrier it is then possible that they
were created for other zonai Warriors to
practice combat with but that's neither
here nor there ultimately they are
combat zonai constructs that were
created for the purpose of training a
fighter and even have a very large weak
spot but speaking of which that leads me
to the next zonai construct boss the
seized construct which is faced as the
boss of the spirit Temple now this one
also has a pretty simple explanation see
rauru's older sister moneru was a
tinkerer and an inventor in fact she and
Zelda Were Somehow able to get the
sheikah warp functions working well
before any sheikah constructions were
present in the world based solely off of
information derived from the sheikah
Slate I mean the purapad so yeah she's
kind of an era defining Super Genius she
was also very interested in researching
the concept of bonding one's spirit with
Machinery which she actually ended up
doing by bonding herself within the
purapad and eventually Awakening to talk
to link and get him to build a new
crafter construct from within the
construct Factory why she decided to not
talk to link before this point and maybe
brief him about some of the stuff that
went down ages ago who knows but either
way the seized construct boss is a
gloom-infected crafter construct that is
exactly like the one link assembles
under the instruction of mineru its
possession by Gloom is extremely similar
to the way that the sheikah constructs
would be possessed by malice in breath
of the wild the final non-gloom created
boss and tears of the Kingdom would be
Master Koga Top Banana Nana of the yiga
clan himself now I know he appeared in
breath of the wild and therefore has an
explanation in my breath of the wild
boss lore video but he's a living
character who actually has some stuff
happened to him in between games that's
worth mentioning if you'll recall upon
being bested by Link in breath of the
wild he was pushed by himself down the
eagle hole which previously had left his
fate unanswered by now of course we know
that this hole is really just a Chasm
that leads down Into the Depths which
kogus survived falling into somehow
anyway once down in the depths he was
able to somehow contact his other yiga
clan members and begin moving the
operations down there with the new name
of the game being Ultra hand zonite and
the zonai constructs koga's new planet
tears of the Kingdom before being beaten
once again by link of course is to build
yet another crafter construct in order
to beat link and gain the attention of
the demon king who I'm pretty sure
doesn't even know that Koga exists
ouch his fate is once again left up to
our imagination since the last thing we
see of him is his muscular body being
blasted off by one million zonai Rockets
of his own creation but you know somehow
I'm sure he still survived you may have
noticed there's one boss left in tears
of the Kingdom to talk about and that
would be the one the only Ganondorf
dragmire also known as The Demon King
himself also known as the demon dragon
but you see there's actually not much
solid evidence given to us in the game
that would enable us to fully explain
ganondorf's actions and tears of the
Kingdom which means it is time for a
theory so once again make sure you're
subscribed so you know when part two
comes out because between myself and my
good buddy ran over on my Discord server
we're pretty sure we've got this
Ganondorf thing all figured out on
another note though thank you so much
for watching did you learn anything new
about the bosses of Tears of the Kingdom
or did I miss a detail let me know in
the comments below and please consider
leaving a like on the video If you
enjoyed it or at least my efforts into
making it huge thanks as always to my
Bandit crew who make my day every day
and are the reason the channel can stay
alive and continue producing
passionately geeky content that's all
for now so follow me on my socials and
I'll see you next time this is Bandit
signing out
[Music]